[Music]
it's probably not a big surprise that
luck is often other people luck is
created by other people helping us out
and sociologists have that wonderful
term of weak ties which means that it's
the people who you aren't necessarily
closest to who often can do the most for
you your very close friends your family
members tend to know the same people
that you do they know the same
opportunities that you do but it's that
next circle that's slightly wider circle
that's likely to bring in new
opportunities for you we're not talking
about Facebook friends here I'm talking
about having colleagues and friends and
friends who you meet who you talk to who
you bring into your circle and who are
very likely then to help you find other
opportunities one thing we found is that
often people who cross over in different
categories in different social classes
and different economic classes like
fitness trainers or hairdressers
tend to be really interesting people for
bringing luck because they know so many
different people from so many different
categories so it may be a surprise that
while you're there trying to improve
your biceps you happen to mention the
job you'd like and the guy who's helping
you hold the weights happens to know
somebody who might be able to help again
what's really important as you build
those bigger circles as you build those
luck circles is to know very
specifically what you're looking for
because if you put out that general idea
it's not going to go anywhere but if you
can be very specific about what you're
wanting sometimes those weak ties really
can lead to something very unexpected
and very important in the book I talk
about Shelley's Thoreau and the Academy
award-winning actress who came to
America when she was about 19 and she
came after a series of unfortunate
events in South Africa she had a pretty
traumatic and difficult childhood
growing up including her mother
murdering her father and she went to
Italy first she wanted to be a dancer
and then her knees gave out he says one
piece of bad luck after another in the
life but shirley's knew what she wanted
to do and she came to America she came
to Los Angeles to give herself one last
chance to put herself in the place where
Luck could find her well it wasn't doing
such a great job at finding
she was in a bank the teller wouldn't
cash a check that her mom had sent from
South Africa and she had a meltdown and
a fit well guess what somebody who was
standing near her in the bank happened
to be a talent agent handed her his card
and the rest is oscar-winning history
now I'm not suggesting that you should
have a fit in a bank in order to become
lucky but I think some of the elements
of what Charlize did actually show that
we do make that luck happen she did push
on she did decide to come to Los Angeles
she knew what she wanted she was focused
on what she wanted and when that talent
agent handed her the card she called him
and she had the talent and the tenacity
to go ahead and make that happen again
so yes again there is that random moment
that somebody happened to be standing in
the bank but you have to think that when
somebody has put so much effort into
something has put so much thought into
something that there's a good chance
that if it wasn't that Bank it was going
to be a different situation where
somebody noticed her and somebody
recognized her you have to put yourself
in the place for good things to happen
and that's what she did
[Music]
you